so
so
so
hello i think we're live are we live
let's do this see what the comments say
not not quite yet but hi hello and
welcome
to our xbox series x and s launch day
live stream i'm michael hi i'm
joined by my good friend jacob decker
say what's up man we're competing with
xbox they're doing a launch day live
stream too
ooh but ours is better though so uh so
thank you for everyone for uh for tuning
in and uh yeah we're about to get into
some
some some games uh because we are here
to celebrate the
xbox series x and s but we're playing on
the x so
what we're trying to do today is i got
jake on the sticks
because he is a professional video game
player and a magical video producer
uh but yeah he is playing off the x
no you're both those things so he's
playing on the series x and you're
watching his gameplay
and i'm michael i reviewed the xbox
series x and s
uh for game spot so while he's playing
some games
i'm going to kind of be talking through
what's uh what what y'all are going to
be seeing uh here on the screen
but also i'll be fielding some questions
and i'll get to them throughout the
stream
and then maybe a little later we're
gonna do some co-op gears
uh him and i and i'll be playing off the
series s uh because that's how i got my
setup over here got a cute little cute
little xbox in the series s
i would show y'all but it's hooked up
right here so uh yes
again thank you for joining us uh this
is forza horizon 4
and we are this stream is in 1080p
but forza horizon 4 is one of the games
that did get
series x enhancements such as
4k 60fps
and so you know it's it's running smooth
uh and i know that the
xbox one x did uh did 1080p 60 i believe
but the series x is able to do 4k 60
and we're gonna show off jake uh driving
around uh
word on the street is he's not a great
driver but uh i don't know
we'll be the judge of that uh one thing
to point out is that we
this isn't 4k uh the stream isn't 4k
because my internet would probably peel
over and die
so uh if you're wondering where the 4k
gameplay is we have some videos up on
gamespot now where you can kind of check
out 4k gameplay but this in particular
is i think it's out it's outputting at
1080p
um but it it should be 60 frames a
second it once again if my internet is
uh
you know withstanding the burden of this
hey listen uh it's it's tough doing
these things from home
because the conditions are less than
ideal sometimes but
we do what we can so um as jake drives
around
where you're gonna try and find a race
or something yeah let's do that
i i played a little bit of this game i
really liked it
top gear chapters complete huh i like
liked it but i just
racing games are hard for me to like
spend a lot of time on
oh yeah i can i can sink into a racing
game for a while i was actually playing
forza motorsport 7
the other night i was chilling i i just
dipped like five hours into that game i
i love me some races
i mean i do too i think it's more just
the fact that like
like racing games are one of those games
where like i can play like an hour or
two of it and i get the idea of it and
i'm like okay this is how this game
feels
right i know what to expect uh but
there's other stuff i have to play for
work or there's like story games that i
want to get through so usually
that's when i'll kind of fall off but i
really do
like racing games even though i'm not
very good at it and i especially
appreciate these
sports and games um yeah this game is
stunning and the sound design is so good
yeah yeah definitely uh i i can't i
can't get game audio but i know
from my hours with forza horizon it's
definitely one of those showcase games
too
because it's a first party xbox game it
gets all kinds of optimizations
uh looks great runs great uh and it
looked great on the
1x obviously but the combination of
4k 60fps is
magical it's a magical thing um so yeah
ford is a great game uh you're gonna do
a couple races so today um
we're actually gonna be jumping between
a few different games and i think that
it'll give you an idea of
like how the series x and s uh ecosystem
works
uh jumping between games and all that
and uh yeah we're gonna give you a
little bit of variety to also
show off the different capabilities of
each um
like the what the series x offers to
different games so for example like i
said
the enhancements with forza horizon 4
even though they're not coming through
on the live stream
uh it is nice to kind of talk through
that a little bit but we all also we're
also going to be playing secure shadows
die twice
a backwards compatible game without
enhancements uh
but it does get boosts based on just
having the stronger hardware
so that's a very good that's one of my
favorite cases of the series x boosting
a game
without optimizations so you're gonna
get smooth 60 frames per second
and that's really important for secure
because that game is tough and jake is
very good at it so i'm
actually excited to see him um i'm not
trying to boost you too much but
uh yeah i was i was trying those new
trials last week and they were very hard
yeah okay uh hey maybe we see him
struggle but hey it's gonna be
it's gonna be six smooth uh in
performance mode and that really helps
really helps the gameplay experience for
that so we're going to show that off
a little bit we're also going to like i
said earlier we're going to jump into
the gears 5 co-op
um because gears 5 does uh have some
slight improvements in the single player
obviously we can't show off 120 hertz in
multiplayer uh
just by nature of limitations on capture
and display
like unless you uh a lot of variables
there but
um yeah gears is also one of those first
party games it just uh
looks and runs great uh gets some
optimizations
uh with the series x and what's the
other what's the other game we're gonna
get into
that we have on deck yakuza
wow how did i forget so uh we're
definitely gonna jump into yakuza like a
dragon you all should peek my review of
yakuza like a dragon because i reviewed
that game
uh my game of the year like real talk
that's
yoga like a dragon is my game of the
year uh and
it's also a one of the premier series x
launch titles
which is wild because it's a
traditionally a playstation
exclusive game but yeah we're going to
show off the oxy-like dragon launch
today
such a special game to me but also it
takes advantage of some of the series x
uh hardware
uh we'll show off it's like high
resolution mode we'll just show off its
uh high fps mode
uh and you'll get an idea of how that
game runs
and what the series x is capable of uh
so yeah we have four games on
deck that we want to get to we may also
jump to
um if time permits uh jump to a few
other things
i know you have watchdogs legion on deck
also uh which we've
shown yeah which we've shown off uh
quite a few times but
it just got its ray tracing update
okay yeah and i also see bright memory
there too which is a pretty wild case
uh if we want to get into that later
memory is strange it's very short like
i've like what's there you can do in
like 20 minutes i did it
i think we actually have 4k gameplay
footage of that up on our
one of our youtube channels if you want
to check that out but that was
interesting because
it had like a full-on graphics suite
like you could change the anastrophic i
think that does pronounce filtering and
like uh
and like there was like vsync settings
and stuff it was very strange
oh wow yeah sounds sounds like they just
like put over a pc version of the game
um yeah that's that's pretty wild but
yeah damn slipping and sliding man come
on you need a
hey i'm not in last if you're not first
you're last
yeah i know that's what they say uh so
while drake jake uh slips and slides in
his lambo
i don't know why he's driving a lambo in
the snow but hey
props to him uh for trying but uh
i wanna get to some questions real quick
and also uh
i haven't been fans of the chat quite
yet but if you are in the chat
uh drop some questions if you already
dropped it drop them again so i can uh
so i can see them
also if levels need adjusting let me
know too and i can
adjust that like if someone's too quiet
game audio is too loud whatever it might
be
uh i can adjust that the best i can is a
bit of a strange setup though so
bear with me yeah i'm surprised we can
even make this work
uh jake has been putting on a lot of
work to make this happen and a lot of
folks behind the scenes so
um i hope you all enjoy okay
uh i'm gonna check the chat real quick
go from the bottom up uh see what y'all
recently been saying
uh sorry i i i can't read i'm a decent
writer but
you know um i have trouble reads okay
t-razer 176 says what's the best-looking
game on the
on x right now subjective
of course but i will say that
um i think like showcase wise like this
and gears 5 probably
are the best but like a game like ori
you know you can't really compare
that to it because it's got a very
distinct art style which i think is
really good
yeah and also if you can run or
if you can if you have 120 hertz display
and you're playing ori
uh i think that game really shines it
really shows off the the smoothness
of bumping up the frames per second and
the refresh rate
um that's really cool but yeah i still
think four zen gears are some of the
best showcases
yakuza is a tricky case because it's
still running off the dragon engine
which is
a new engine but it's not like the most
mind-blowing when it comes to certain
aspects of it
i think the the character models are
very impressive um
that's what i'll say about that and the
the
the way it's able to do city density
while still
looking really really nice like the
interiors look really good in yakuza
like going inside buildings and whatnot
there we go first hey see not first or
less
congrats uh but yeah so i think though
those are
some some decent showcases i think you
know what i was playing assassin's creed
valhalla last night
and i'm impressed that it runs 60 fps
and looks that good
yeah because i don't think that's really
good there's any like
enhancement options right like it is
just here's how you're gonna play and
it's 4k60 and
it looks good because wasn't there that
like initially they were like it's going
to be 4k 30
on consoles and everyone was like uh
yeah there were some rumblings about
that
um there might be um
some uh like dynamic resolution stuff
i'm not 100 sure quite yet i want to
look into it
um but it it looks great and i'm
surprised by playing an assassin's creed
game at 60 fps on a console because i've
been playing on pc here and there
um but that is really cool i think that
um yeah you should definitely keep the
ac valhalla a lot after this
keep the ac valhalla live stream that
jake actually did with lucy
you want to see the 4k yeah definitely
uh because y'all put that
review out in 4k so definitely check
that out
and uh also i think watchdogs legion is
also another
case that i think is is i would say
it's a showcase for what it what the
series x can do so it has full
ray tracing now uh that's part of the
series x update
and i have mixed feelings about ray
tracing or how it's been implemented in
watchdog's legion
because when it starts to rain it looks
like the entire place is covered in
olive oil
ray tracing i feel like is going to go
through a similar thing that like
like do you remember like early 360
generations or all the characters would
look like rubber
i feel like ray tracing is gonna have
something like that or it's just like
sure we gotta retrace
everything to hell yeah uh so it can't
look odd in some places but i think
the reflections off of cars windows and
puddles
uh it's it's really really cool you
don't really like stop
and notice it but it adds to how the
world
feels a lot more realistic photo
realistic i would say so watch out
legion is a good case of where the
series x uh and or these next gen
consoles can go
so definitely check that out it runs out
of 4k 30
which is understandable because ray
tracing is a very demanding
graphics feature but it looks uh
pretty damn nice is what i'll say
ah let's see if i can plug any questions
from the chat real quick sorry i'm
trying trying to keep up uh trying to
trying to keep talking
and all that um but i also have we also
rounded up some questions
um previously before the stream went
live so i'll also get to those
um make sure folks get their questions
answered
oh we got one from evan langer oh big
fan of gamespot evan langer
the the new yawkes is called like a
dragon but the characters look like like
a human can you clarify this discrepancy
well play the game and then you will get
your answer
i'll tell you that much evan uh let's
see
let let me see any tv work with hdmi 2.1
um you check the specs yeah i've been
doing that i got
an lg bx bx all day
bx tv also the lg cx i think
a don't quote me on this
a sony is it x900
i think those have hdmi 2.1 i think
samsung q60s or better
have hdmi 2.1 so a lot of the high-end
tvs have
uh hdmi 2.1 and
that means that they should be able to
do 120 hertz 4k
which is series x is capable of and some
games
some games take advantage of but those
are pretty expensive tvs
don't a lot i only have like one hdmi
2.1 port too as well so you
if you get like an xbox series x and ps5
you might have to uh
like swap hot swap those um
so i'd wait for rich people problems
uh no the one i got was hooked up by
gamespot so it's not mine because i
would never drop 1500 bucks on the tv or
i was like 1200.
but um that's two hdmi 2.1 ports
you know flex a little bit um
let's see uh speaking of series x does
it have stated capability to actually
play original xbox and 360 games
addition to backwards compatible games
with the xbox one um can uh
2006 2012 hdtv work yeah yeah as long as
it has hdmi
like uh it's gonna work uh you'll be
fine
um and backwards compatibility works the
same as it
did on xbox one so any 360 or
original xbox games that worked on on
the one
will work on the series consoles and of
course
every xbox one game will work on the
series consoles as well
microsoft put in that work to make sure
back back and pat is
on point and it's uh it's really
exciting because today
uh game patch is updated with ea play
and i'm looking at ea play stuff
and wow there's like i'm gonna want to
replay dead space mirrors oh mirror's
edge is already on game pass
but like uh the original dead space two
and three
all the battlefield games madden 15 if
you want to go back
that's pretty they got mad at 15 all the
way up to last year's mad
i guess i'll take it it's weird that
those are still available because i know
like microsoft like you can't get forza
horizon 3 anymore or soon you'll be able
to get forza horizon 3. like they take
off old racing games yeah
and like of all the games to take off
your store i feel like it would be
old sports games but it's good it's
still there like history-wise just so
history of madden you want to play
through all 50 freaking madden games
but ages seem strange let's see uh
go back a little bit uh soul swag 817
man i got that swag you i do anything
new uh
not really it has dynamic backgrounds
but it's pretty limited what you can do
with the dynamic background
i haven't messed with it too much but
the ui is pretty much what you got
on the xbox one now but it's
super snappy is what i'll say quicker
zoom is is new them
yeah quicker zoom is i guess you can
lump that into how the ui works
because you are going in and out of
games pretty rapidly
and i think that is that's one of my
favorite features
because i'd be jumping between a lot of
different games especially with
something like game pass where
i doubt it's like a buffet yo i'm like
hella hungry and i just want everything
so i
doubt i fill up my hard drive um and
then i'm like damn what do i want to
play
so i play a little bit of everything and
then like jumping between uh for quick
resume and i settled on like two or
three games that i want to like focus on
and uh yeah i get my feel of one
type of game or genre and then i jump to
the next uh so i've been playing like
master chief collection
then i bump out and then go into forza
do some races there
bump out of that and then jump into
yakuza like things like that i think
that really improved the experience you
know so you're not sitting around
waiting because you want to make the
most of your time some people got
limited time to play games
and features like that and the super
fast load times really make
like if you sit down and play games you
can spend like i said before
more time gaming less time waiting so i
think that's really neat
it's good you're here because the the
amount of concentration i need to play
racing games
is very high there's no way i guess
answer questions look at chat i'd be
hitting walls crashing all the time yeah
you're not trying to play bumper cars
out here but i under i understand man
when i try look at the nicholas cage
looking at us over here
that's my profile picture
oh man but uh yeah it's uh
sometimes i stream on my own and i'm
like damn this is this is tough
how do i how do i even do this um but
let me catch up with the chat real quick
tell the folks how you're feeling today
jake like what's what's your movie
uh i'm excited like i don't know i've
been
playing i've been lucky enough to play
the series x now for the past couple
weeks
um so uh like it doesn't feel like a
i mean still feels like a brand new
console but it doesn't feel like i just
opened it and set it up and playing it
which is a very cool feeling and i'm
sure people will be very excited to do
that but
uh i i don't know i'm stoked to be
streaming streaming is fun
and especially on shiny new consoles and
whatnot
yeah man and we're gonna play some good
games
oh and we can show off the share feature
we're gonna tweet some stuff to the
official
gamespot account listen gamespot messed
up they gave us the
keys twitter account so you know we're
good hey
we're gonna we're gonna take advantage
of that uh but yeah that's also to show
up some of the share features
i think the controller has a share
button and i think that makes things
so much more easier than they used to be
on the one on xbox one
and the way the old controller worked so
let's show that off it's a little bit
easier but also we're gonna we're gonna
tweet some
some wild things i think we're just
gonna tweet a bunch of yakuza
screenshots which
it's the goat
someone mentions mentioned tetris yeah
tetris connected is
on xbox series xbox one and series
consoles uh it's pretty wild um
because tetris is a beautiful beautiful
game um
you want the load times for tetris oh
damn i don't know
stalled yeah i can't help you on that
but um
i'm sure they are very fast
someone say can you show new games yeah
that's why we got yakuza coming up
just hold your horses but yeah there's a
couple of new games um
obviously ac valhalla which we streamed
yesterday uh falconer is also another
game that
uh came out for alongside series x
um and a whole bunch of games that got
enhanced specifically
um for the series x and
s so um
can i buy a warthog in this game i want
a warthog
i thought i thought like if you got like
the season pass or something it was
automatically put into your garage
because i i was i got the special
edition of this game
and then i think that's how it worked
and then all the sun is like hey you got
a warthog
oh there's also the races i'm doing
maybe the races i'm doing because i've
only done like
it seems like esteer
there is there is a specific race in the
game
where you race the warthog
music yes yes yeah
because it goes along the beach so it
kind of looks like uh
silent cartographer is that this is so
cool that it's on the beach or something
something silent cartography is on the
beach yeah
yeah so it kind of like it's reminiscent
of that and has like
uh grunts and like plasma shots going
off in the distance
or whatever it's really wild because i'm
like this is a forza game
but yeah i think that's how you get the
get the warthog there's a specific
race i can't remember where because it's
been years oh look it
did that look at this dry guitar see who
it was
pancake face you know what that is who's
who's pancake face margarita
oh snap crash them into the walls
damn i miss that guy that was our former
xbox boy
i forget about the drivatar thing in
this game like it was such a big feature
when like
the xbox one launched they were like man
you can race your friends even when
you're not they're not playing
and now it's like in all the games and
i'm like oh yeah now i'm like
kicking nick's ass at forza and he can't
do nothing about it
like matt padgett is one of my few i
think jean-luc and matt
are one of my few friends on xbox and
every time i play forza
and forza motorsport i'm always matt for
some reason matt is always
the one who's like leading the pack and
i have to overtake him
so in every race i'm just beating
beating the [ __ ] out of matt
so shouts out to matt padgett because
that boy that was bad
he put in a lot of work for that ps5
review so shouts out to him
but that is coming later or that's
already published but
ps5 launches in a couple days but for
now we're talking xbox
uh so let me see if i got some new
questions in the chat
um mario lopez uh says
question will you do a comparison video
between game running on series x uh
where's the game running on series s
um i don't do we have anything like that
yeah or
something yeah it's something we've been
talking about doing uh i think it just
kind of depends on the game
like doing it on uh backwards
compatibility games
that haven't received updates might be a
little strange just because
one's running off the xbox one x uh
updates and one doesn't have those even
though they're on i don't know
it gets it gets pretty complicated it's
very tricky um but i think like
it'd be cool for us to do something with
forza in particular
or gears 5 for example um or even some
upcoming
games like i think uh haven't they said
like dmc supports ray tracing on the
what or
not the one x dear god the series x and
the
uh but not on the series s or something
yeah something like that
um so they're we're gonna i think what
we'll try to do is pluck out some
um some good cases that do show off a
difference
and uh go from there we actually only
got one series s
prior to launch uh which is the one i
used for review so we've been a little
bit limited in terms of what we can do
with the series s
but i worry you know
coverage is uh ever evolving and
continuing
so yeah keep your eyes peeled for that
but um just to go off of that
um since i have been able to use the
series s
a little bit is oh this is another
question that was
actually let me jump to a question that
came from the community earlier
um this school is trying to roll for
credits that's not bad 130 000 credits
i'll take it
let me see there is okay here's a
question from
nate grinko uh from the uh youtube
community
chat before we went live with this live
stream
asks how does this series s's 4k
upscaling compares to the x's native 4k
resolution from a basic eye test how
noticeable are the differences
um very good question so for me i was
playing both consoles on a 4k tv
and the the differences were
quite noticeable to me also i'm someone
who's like been
i've been paying attention to these
sorts of things since i was
like since i've been a pc gamer since i
was a little baby man i was like
mama mama this is 1080p 1080p didn't
even exist when i was born what the hell
uh but uh yeah i've been a piece of
gamer for a long time so
uh i do notice those things a lot easier
so to me they do look quite different in
terms of
the fidelity so i'm not saying that the
series s
it will going back to it depends so
for example let's take forza horizon 4
and gears 5 for example
games that got series s optimizations
for both uh yes for series x and s
series s optimizations make those games
look great
um it's not doesn't have the same
clarity as
the series x on a 4k tv but those games
look great
um they look like they're either they're
close they're
if they're not 1440p it looks pretty
damn close to 1440p
it's or if it's a if it's a 1080p those
games looking real crispy on a 4k tv
considering the the power and the size
of the series s
um going to the series x i i can see log
this is a crispy 4k it looks great
series s isn't too far behind but if you
play a backwards compatible game
that hasn't received optimizations the
differences
are super noticeable because
the series s plays the base xbox one
versions of back compact games
if they have not been optimized for
series s
so for example i was playing final
fantasy 15 on the series s
and the bass xbox one version caps off
at 900p resolution so it doesn't do
1080p and it's at like 30 frames per
second
so it doesn't look great it doesn't run
great um
but if you play the series x version you
get the 1x enhancements
so you can choose super high resolution
or higher frame rate the game looks
very looks decent and it runs well
some caveats there for that particular
case
so it's tricky so if it gets series s
optimizations
it looks pretty damn good if it doesn't
if a game doesn't get serious
optimizations it doesn't look that great
especially in comparison to how it will
look if you run it on a series x
case by case basis but moving forward
like
this is something that uh xbox is gonna
take care of in the future
where future releases are gonna be
optimized
for series s and x so i think that
it's a bit of a bummer because backwards
compatibility is such an attractive
thing about
the new consoles but the fact that you
don't get to use
a lot of games don't get to use the the
juice that's packed in the series s
is a little disappointing but i
understand why that's the case
because that'd be a lot of work to go
back it's like okay we now we need
specific enhancements for the series s
and the tech specs don't exactly line up
with the series s and the one x
listen it's it's it's a lot it's a lot
to
kind of um what i will say though is
that
as i said for both console reviews if a
game runs a dynamic resolution
or a 60fps cap or an uncapped frame rate
the series s will be able to maintain
higher resolutions
during dynamic resolution and higher
frame rates in those cases
um it's just that base xbox one games
don't really get to shine all that much
so that's that on that
um damn your boy's been attacking a lot
so i need to take a swedish water i
think we're gonna do
we're gonna do uh off-road race oh what
i still
want i was hoping i'd be able to use
different class of cars but i guess not
do an off-road race with your with your
lambo yeah that's
weird right i don't know yeah
okay um how do i buy cart like is there
like a page where you buy
new cars in this game because i can't
seem to find it other than yeah by car
oh just anything this is just cars that
work for this race
oh uh you'd have to go uh back out and
then go into your
main menu um
i will admit that the forza horizon
menus are up kind of a big mess this is
so much yeah look at all these blocks
tabs with all these blocks
like none of it means anything to me uh
go to wheels
super wheel spin
uh where is it um
i [ __ ] man i don't know i have great
customized cars i'm stupid
i was looking at it uh there you go um
let me uh see what uh what's going on my
bad if i
have missed y'all in the chat um
oh there we go that's what i'm oh i
don't have enough for this
damn you can't even buy a hor oh a whole
heart walk
work um have you guys tried warzone on
the x that is a question for jacob
i have i've done a lot of warzone on the
x it it seems to run
a bit smoother from what i can tell like
there doesn't seem to be as many
dips in frame rate not that there are
many to begin with and it loads much
much faster
like almost it's almost kind of an issue
because i end up not really an issue but
i end up loading into stuff like way
quicker than everyone i'm playing with
uh so so like sometimes i'll just be in
the opening lobby
way before anyone else uh damn i guess
it depends though right because there's
also pc people so warzone's pretty well
adjusted to that but when i play like
regular multiplayer in call of duty
um with uh cross play disabled then
usually
it's uh i'm usually the first in
that's what's up those load times is uh
it took me got it gotta wait
so fast travel even should we switch or
should we do one more race
um we already see we're about 30 minutes
you want to switch over to sekiro
let's do it okay so jake was
jake was pretty decent at forza you know
um
i got first on all three four races i
did yeah enough nothing to scoff at
but man is about to flex on us
with some secure gameplay hey you
streamed uh when this game first came or
around the time this game came out i
still
streamed your platinum well yeah it's on
xbox though so oh you're you're a
thousand gamers or you're
yeah you're a thousand games
nobody can tell you nothing about your
your second road skills so which
like the getting from software platinums
and whatnot isn't as rare as other ones
because
people who play from software games are
like yeah i'm gonna get the platinum so
yeah um but yeah so the um so we're
transitioning to secure shadows like
twice the reason we're doing that is
because this is a case as i mentioned
earlier
where the series x is able to boost the
performance
for a game without needing optimizations
so um the performance mode uh
caps the frame rate at 60 fps on one x
it wasn't really able to it
would hit around like high 30s 40s
stuff like that but on the series x 60
fps straight up
which is super helpful for a game like
this and also
i i liked uh to i like to show off this
game because you know
uh jake is one of jake's favorite games
of last year
or was it your favorite game last year
uh second favorite i liked uh disco
elysium more
but oh that's right it was it was very
close like
yeah i've spent way more time playing
this game which boss should we do
but it was uh game spots 2019 game of
the year
and it was and it was the keeley winner
too
oh that's right yeah that's pretty cool
surprised me i didn't think it was going
to win
the kiwis the killings
oh man but yeah this is a game again oh
no
you're rusty and you're jumping right
into genitaro
but yeah if you are watching this um i
think
yeah we're streaming this in 60 fps so
you can see this game running i mean if
you played on pc
you you've been able to play at 60fps
but the fact that this is uh
on a console without optimizations
uh it's a pretty neat benefit and there
there are other games
that are able to do this such as no
man's sky
uh no man's sky is uh benefit benefits
straight 60
the entire time monster hunter world is
also another game that
benefits greatly i remember playing well
i played monster in the world on a bass
ps4
not the best case uh but jumping into
monster in the world
in on the series x obviously a big
difference but it is a game that
runs at a 60fps cap and the game is able
to
hit that 60fps cap um
homeboy is getting a wreck yeah this is
rough mission has started with guinea
that's all right but yeah you see in
those silky smooth frame rates on a
console
um version of the game that's pretty
cool
uh let's see um
uh uh gaming lizard has a question from
your experience on console launches if
you didn't get a pre-order how realistic
do you think it is to get a new console
this year a little different
obviously different situations uh there
are a lot of rumblings about people who
even did pre-order not being able to get
theirs
uh complete enough um which is
unfortunate but
such is the case uh in this in the year
of warlord 2020
um obviously i can't speak to it because
i'm not a retailer
i'm also not with microsoft logistics
and all that
um i'm just going off the top of the
brain but
um i feel like from what i've seen
in like pc hardware launches is that
you'll see stock coming in and out a lot
um
like maybe half a day it'll be available
in stock
and then it's sold out for the next
couple days so
that's how i think things are going to
play out at least until
next year so yeah it's a little
unfortunate but
such is the world and such is the case
here with
new console launches i remember it was
really hard to get a wii
when that thing first launched um so i'm
kind of
this is my first console generation
launch where i've been able to be in
games media so it's a little different
because we do get these things for work
but i remember younger the wii was hard
to get
at launch 360 i saw in stock
pretty often ps3 was a little tricky
because there was
i think like everyone wanted like the 60
gigabyte version
but the 20 gigabyte version was
available but then like that wasn't
and then but that one did backwards
compatibility or something i don't know
it was it was pretty wild but yeah i
remember there
being some troubles with ps3s and stuff
um
ps4s i don't think there was much uh an
xbox ones
i don't think there was much trouble
there uh switches was probably the most
recent case where
for months people were like yo switch is
in stock
and then a couple hours later psych it
is not in stock no more
um and then it like happened again at
the beginning of this pandemic too
yeah everyone started like trying to
stock up on switches and it's like oh
it's like launch all over again
um i do think that this new console
launch is gonna be like that
where yes like i said stock is gonna be
coming in and out
um experienced that with the switch it
took me a while to get a switch of my
own
um so yeah that's uh that's out on that
let me see what else uh gov is saying if
not i have a well of questions that i
can still get to
um
um i can't hear any gameplay on my end
so that's why it feels a little quiet
uh but i hope y'all are enjoying the
clashing of swords
uh and all that um
does the series x come with the game
pass code i don't think so
mine didn't and i got a actual retail
package
um uh i thought it would if you get like
what's the
thing they are having the the like the
monthly all access yeah yeah
that comes with game pass yeah so i
think
it's like a it's a payment plan you
gotta get a console
and along with game pass ultimate
that's a pretty sweet deal if you uh
don't
like if you bought it i don't know what
the availability looks like in terms of
that because
console availability is limited to begin
with yeah that is a good deal though
um but my package did not come with the
game pass month
code uh so
um let me see
what y'all and scene
uh chuck poiseau uh says
i'll play said that right do you guys
like the series s i think it's a cool
little console
it's not it's not for the it's not for
the
it's not really for the folks who are
like super into gaming who spend a lot
of time gaming
but as you go into the next generation
you have to or you probably want to
offer something
to those who want to get a xbox
but don't necessarily care all that much
about the highest fidelity or
um you know having the latest and
greatest so i see the series s
as a as a very good like if i had kids i
ain't got kids but if i did
and they're like 12 or whatever
and you know they want to play games i
want to get them into games
series s is a great option
limited hard drive space which i or ssd
space sorry
which i think is kind of a bummer but
when i think about who the console's for
i don't know if that's going to be that
big of a deal um
i think it's a big deal personally but
it just depends on who you get it for
or what your expectations are uh when
you get the series bests um yeah
it's an it's a nice little console i'm
glad it exists
uh all things considered uh you know
what i'm saying
let's see how many games can be on quick
resume five right well it depends
uh i was able to in one case i was able
to get seven games
uh rolling at the same time but i had
games like bloodstained
and ori uh some smaller games less
demanding games
uh so i just it just depends on what
games they are
i think with bigger games it like about
five i think
the bummer about quick resume i mean i
don't think this is going to affect that
many people because like
who's really trying to push playing five
seven games at the same time
but it doesn't tell you when another
game has to close its game state
i do wish it did give you sort of an
indication
like hey if you open one more game the
this particular game that you open last
is gonna have to close it doesn't have
that uh but yeah it is about
i would say five games is like a safe
like uh safe amount to kind of
for your expectations to have like
suspended and quick resume
um graphical updates noticed in warzone
um
i don't know if you can speak to that
jake but uh not really i mean like i
said
it seems like it's more down to
performance and especially load times
um i don't know i don't even limited yet
but i think 120 hertz
is supposed to be okay because i i know
part of it like warzone this isn't
warzone supposed to come to next gen
like in december or something like that
like a photo is it so maybe there'll be
an update then that addresses that kind
of stuff
or at least it's coming to black ops i
think in december black ops
that's a mouthful but yeah that game is
supposed to get
uh or we'll have specific enhancements
um if not at launch than somewhere down
the line but yeah that's supposed to do
120 hertz which is pretty dope for a
shooter if you ask me but
um i do think that the use case for 120
hertz is pretty slim i don't think
if you're not a pc gamer you probably
don't have a high refresh rate display
unless you balled out on a on a really
really good tv recently
uh so yep
that's that's one of my favorite bosses
in this game i'll probably mess it up
because it's hard i don't i don't know
why i like
well actually i know i like this much
just like his patterns
are so much fun to fight against
corrupted monk
come on boy oh really look at this the
swings and smooth 60 frames per second
that's what i'm that's what i'm talking
about good god
um
let me see what else uh i have still
have uh some questions to go through
and uh that we sourced
from earlier so we got we we got to name
grinko um talking about
series s upscaling 4k then native for
the x um it depends but yeah i do notice
it
uh is how i uh would sum that up um
oh at irregular dave on twitter hey i
know him i don't know
i feel like we should ban that fool uh
which console smells the best
let me smell my series
smells great both of them smell great
thanks dave keep it moving
um are there any games you hope to get a
remaster or remake
midnight gamer 4x says on twitter um
jake is there anything there's like a
full-on remaster
a remake or just like an xbox series x
update
let's say like a full-on remake to take
full advantage of the series x
we already got demon souls coming we do
have demon souls coming not to the
series x
but yeah but that is out in the
existence
of the world i'll have to think about it
after this fight
okay yeah that's right i don't know why
i asked you while you're in the middle
of a damn
boss fight in second room for me when it
comes to xbox i was to say like hey
persona 3
you know what i'm saying uh that would
be i would cry for
days and days and days if this on a
three remake actually happened but
uh when it comes to like the xbox brand
um
oh wow i was gonna say mass effect we're
getting that it's spring 2021
oh my god n7day gave us
the gifts of god
letting us know that you know mass
effect trilogy remastered oh my god
don't even get started so excited for
that i'm really glad
that they're doing a full-on um it was
always one of those things where i was
like is this even real is this really
gonna happen
people keep talking about it but you
know i haven't we haven't heard anything
uh unless you're on like the inside
inside um
and i'm like yeah that's that's not real
that's not happening
then they hit us with it so god my
timing is just slightly too slow
come on man get good um
other than that i don't know fusion
frenzy
i was thinking that i was thinking of
like
old xbox games i was thinking yeah
fusion frenzy and was it kung fu chaos
which hey ninja oh yo that's wild yeah i
didn't think of that
fusion frenzy is on game pass but you
give me a
4k 120 hertz full
remake of fusion frenzy parties is about
to be
we about to turn up at parties when we
can again
i don't know who knows what that will be
i was playing uh halo 2 last night and i
was like
man i think i'm ready for that halo for
a halo 3 remake now
like a full-on yeah like you know they
did the
the one for halo 1 and halo 2.
that what what like like the updated
graphics you know you can like swap
right yeah
look but something like that wait halo 3
does it
oh that's right because it's running the
360. yeah okay all right yeah
nevermind um was great i am getting my
ass kicked
um what was my favorite original xbox
game was actually
the original splinter cell they wanna
you know
hit us but i know i know splinter cell
is a multi-plat multi-platform
game or it always has been
but you give give us like uh one two
like cause
pandora you can't play pandora tomorrow
on modern pcs i don't think
and i don't know if i think they were i
don't know if they work on xbox actually
i should probably uh check myself before
i wreck myself but pandora's tomorrow is
um not many people talk about that
anymore because obviously chaos theory
is the best one
um but that that that kind of those
three games
uh i like double agent i think it's cool
uh wasn't my favorite
but i did like it i finally played
double agent on like
the xbox and ps2 yeah that game which is
different than the 360
and actually i don't think there was a
ps3 version in pc version
uh because it's on xbox backwards
compatible so you can play it
it's pretty good it's everyone i i saw
people saying it was like
almost as good as chaos theory no but
it's
pretty good yeah
yeah i think that that would be really
cool like it's wild because like chaos
theory
almost still like for a very long time
chaos theory was
felt like a like going into the 360
era cassidy still felt like a current
gen game
yeah i think it was like the best case
uh also the game is very dark so you can
probably hide some of the blemishes
a lot easier but that game looked
incredible
um i think it was like the best looking
original xbox game uh i do like that
game a lot
i'm sure those stories have not aged
well but you know what sam fisher
and um lambert and grimm's daughter
that's the squad right i was playing uh
uh conviction not that long ago and
that story has not ached well
there are some things there's some
scenes that like that like
a are kind of problematic but like more
so just the fact that it's like sam
fisher would never do this
like this weird like edgy sam fisher
they introduced
later on just just would not do the [ __ ]
that he's doing now but you know
they were trying to get that action game
i don't know
excuse me yeah i i do feel a little
uh conflicted about conviction um
i think it's a good game i just don't
know if it was a splinter cell game
that i wanted but that's that's fine you
know
you got to try something new every now
and then and i respect that
um so yeah that's my answer my
long-winded answer
uh let me get back to the let's see what
y'all
let's see i
have highlighted question marks so let's
see
question what about dynamic themes they
seem to be on their preview units but on
my series x i can't choose between
uh different dynamic themes oh that's
weird you can only choose color i'm
pretty sure like the dynamic theme is
always going to be
okay it's always going to be this
yeah you see here you can change color
at least from
i was taking a look at it this morning
and i'm pretty sure that's about it oh
okay we're still playing damn didn't
even pause the game for you
oh man so yeah dynamic themes
they're pretty limited now uh i hope
that they would the
xbox would maybe um
lean into a little bit more going
forward because it is a thing that's
been on
playstation i think it's really cool
especially when you get them game by
game
some really really good dynamic themes
out there on playstation so
uh maybe that's a personal five one two
three
persona five yeah it is nice
yeah um someone asked what game this is
this is secure shadows bad twice
uh 2019 game spot game of the year and
um the latest from
from software at least for now showing
this off because
like i said at the front it's able to
run a stable 60 frames per second
unlike the xbox one x version that kind
of dipped
a lot in frame rate around 30 40 fps
so that's that's a really cool and
without optimizations
like i said uh there's a really cool
feature of some backwards compatible
games that do
have that can run higher frame rates but
hasn't been able to hit them
uh now they can my timing is just
off ever so slightly
uh let's see um
got a question from
here we go uh let's see
okay let's see
oh my god if you have a smart delivery
if you have smart delivery enabled on
xbox one game
installed on an external transfer that's
the series x
ssd will it convert to the series x
version or do you have to be done with
the game entirely
so in my experience
when i move a game file
from hard drive to hard drive this is
this is true when moving games from the
series s to the x
is that when you move the game
for example like like um
uh so this is a question from kurt yazda
yazda
zade hopefully i said that right and
when you take a game from an external
hard drive and you move it to the
internal on a series x
if you try to start the game it'll say
hold up
we're downloading some updates so you
won't have to download the entire game
but it will download the necessary asset
package
for the series x specific
um like the series x specific files to
make sure that it's running the correct
version
which is uh yeah that's how that works
so uh and for example like
i've been moving games between series x
and s on a hard drive
so i would take like the gears 5 the
series s
the smaller 55 gigabyte version of gears
5 from the series
s move it to the series x and then it'll
be like hold up we're downloading
the necessary files it'll take a minute
and then it's ready to go so that's kind
of
how that how that's able to work there
because through smart like smart
delivery isn't something you
toggle on or off it's just like quick
resume it's just the way the system
works
uh you don't even have to think about it
um
but yeah that's that's how the system
will take care of uh different versions
of gaming
all right let's see what else y'all been
saying
guessing all the times uh so once uh
wicked juice says guessing low times on
the series s are slower
they are not um so the series x and s
use the same
architecture same ssd so load times will
be
almost identical between consoles i know
phil spencer has said that
um in some cases maybe the series s
might be slightly slightly faster
because it doesn't have
as big of assets to load into but at
least in the cases i've
i've been i just did some quick tests to
make sure that it checked out
it's been pretty much the same because
they are using the same ssd
same architecture and all that so that
is a benefit that
spans both series s and x that you'll
get of course you got to concede
the size of the hard drive a series s
you only got 364 gigabytes available
which is not a lot but like i said
earlier uh when you think about who the
series s is for
maybe that's not as big of a deal
um aqua said earlier what tv
you use i use an lg bx
bx all day uh uh this is an
msi 1440p monitor
so it does one 44 hertz but it doesn't
have 2.1 so i can't do
4k 60 or 4k 120
yeah whatever yeah yeah but i can do 120
hertz at 1080p which i was
best around gears with in gears
multiplayer which was cool
yeah that's kind of cool uh someone said
uh ray tanner said how's the input lag
big difference
not really i mean sorry whoa whoa
sorry uh implaca really just depends on
your
mostly on your display i think that's
the biggest factor
some folks been saying that the
controller is more responsive
hasn't been no if it is it hasn't been
noticeable to me
i feel like the xbox wireless kind of
ecosystem has been really on point
regardless so
hopefully that answers uh some of
y'all's questions
uh let me see what if there's anything
else if not
i will pull from the well
so uh yeah the question about dynamic
themes that was tobias
hopefully that answered
so pinch blues quite any update on the
gta series
well gta 5 is going to get its
its a next-gen update soon i forgot when
that's supposed to come i don't know if
it's early next year or
uh later this year but there is going to
be a
next-gen specific version of gta 5
so if you are play i know a lot a lot a
lot of people
play still play gta online so you get a
little bit of a perk there
it's kind of cool i i don't i'm not sure
if you have to rebuy it
i think i think on ps5 at least um
but yeah that's gta 5 span 3 console
generations
believe that i'd be more curious in a uh
red bed for series x because like that
pc version looks incredible
and like just something closer to that
on console would be amazing
yeah obviously red dead redemption 2 or
you talk about original red deck or
red dead redemption okay yeah obviously
it's backwards compatible
and it's a lot more consistent i think
and you get that's
the load times are much much much faster
but there are no series x specific
enhancements
uh i don't know if they're coming or if
they're planned or whatever
but um you do it it runs the 1x
enhancements
uh and also a lot more consistently but
yeah
again like i said uh no specific series
enhancements
uh for that yeah or if ever
um can i play fortnite yes
four knight actually got fournette
actually got a uh
gotta launched a series x update uh so i
think it runs
4k 60 series s runs uh 1080p
60 i think with some extra there's also
some extra graphical features that come
along with it
so it's not just resolution and frame
rate i think they said stuff about like
improved physics
clear visual flares things like that uh
but yeah
if you play fortnite you're gonna have
the best version of fortnite
if you don't play already play on pc
clearly i should have practiced some
sekiro before today that's on you
uh now it's all good it's all good at
least you're able to
uh keep up in some regard that's what's
important right
so one one thing i'm not sure about with
this though is that this
is new game plus like five and i don't
know if the reflections of strength
are as tough as these bosses are
on uh what the [ __ ] is that move
i haven't seen this phase either because
normally i just assassinate him this
phase and it's easy
uh but but i don't know if like these
enemy these bosses are as hard as they'd
be on new game plus five or if they're
just
their standard one but anyway it is
almost
another 30 minutes should we switch to
yakuza or gears
um let's switch to yakuza if you're
feeling it
all right yeah yeah
my gaming ah i'm hyped for this i will
not do story stuff just in case there's
people in the chat who want to see
that but i'm about 10 hours in so it's
not super far in
uh and i have all of the well at least
i have the the four party members that
they show off
i don't know if there's more or not i
haven't played more there there's
there's more but they're also
uh the fact that they join your party is
a little bit of a spoiler okay
yeah but yeah we're going to show off
some jake's going to be
playing some yakuza like a dragon um
one of my favorite games in a very long
time but um
well the one of the games that have been
pushed uh very
very hard for um the series x launch
um which is really like i said earlier
it's it's pretty wild to see
a you know a japanese game that's
traditionally a playstation exclusive
yeah look at that look at that seconds
bro and
like this loads the entire open world so
if you want to pull up the map
uh this game is uh a lot bigger than
kamurocho
in previous yakuza games so that entire
map was loaded in
was it like three four seconds i
recorded like six seconds
yeah in my first five or six seconds of
my test but that's i think that was a
lot
shorter um so that is an example of
series x load times and if you want to
get more specific low time tests
jake is mr video comparison over here
he's done videos on 1x and series x low
time differences
he also did ps5 to xbox series x
low time comparisons uh so you
definitely check that out
after this stream um to show that off
because i think that's a really really
cool feature that
is really going to improve next-gen
experiences
almost as much as visuals i think um
wayne harrison said that uh red original
2 4k 30 on series x
and it stays 30 yeah and but it um on
one x it jumps from like 30 dips to
25 20. yeah and that's what digital
foundry
recorded so shouts out to digital
foundry for all the work that they do
because they put in
they get very very detailed very good at
what they do but yeah
that's an example of the series x being
able to maintain
uh those higher frame rates i mean
obviously like 30 fps is not high but
red dead is capped at 30 and the series
x is able to stay at 30
because of the power whereas the 1x
might um
dip here and there uh so
that's that on that but yeah we're we're
watching jake
uh roll through roll through yokohama
and yakuza like dragon so this is one of
my favorite games of the year for vera
story reasons and i'm a big yakuza fan
played the entire series and got into it
recently too i think it was like
uh 2017 when downtown peter brown
and jean-luc's uh jean-luc spicy are our
good friends good boys
uh put me on the yakuza series and it
was a love at first sight
but yeah this is uh like a dragon is a
good starting point for those who have
never played a yakuza game because it
starts off a whole new story arc
there are references and callbacks to
the original games but they're not
entirely necessary in order to
understand what's happening in the game
all new stories starring kasuga ichiban
probably one of my favorite characters
of all time this dude is
i love you so much
yeah he's um he's like he's a kid at
heart so the whole thing is like
the reason why you have wild rpg battles
is because
in his mind everything to him is like
playing dragon quest
when he gets into fights he envisions it
as an rpg so that's
what you what you see on screen during
battles is his imagination running wild
and it's adorable i love him so much and
he just
he fights for what's right and it really
carries him through
and a lot of the characters too help him
uh kind of grow because he's kind of
immature in some points in the story but
others are there to like help him grow
and i think that's like that's one of my
favorite things about this game
but yeah if you have a series x i highly
recommend picking this up
uh looks great um does 4k 30fps
uh i know dragon engine isn't like the
most
advanced tech out there but it's still
like this yokohama looks
beautiful yeah especially like some of
the
like neon alleyways look really good
yeah like if you
roll through you were just on isuzuzaki
road which is one of the busier shopping
centers in yokohama in real life also
um yeah yeah it just uh looks wonderful
so yeah you can also so you have two
options
when you play this game on series x and
series s
uh you have high resolution mode so on
series x yakuza will play at 4k 30 like
i said earlier
but if you set it to normal mode it'll
play 1440p
60 frames per second so if you're not
familiar with like resolutions and stuff
it just means that the
image will be a little bit blurrier
slightly lower resolution but 1440p is
still
still looks pretty good uh and 60fps
uh is very noticeable uh change i jumped
between the two
throughout my time playing i just really
like how the game looks at 4k
native 4k during cutscenes
because you get really detail a lot of
up close shots of
people's faces and their expressions and
all that so i do prefer
that for this particular game and it's a
turn-based system so
it's not like you're playing fps where
60 fps is going to like really improve
your skills um but you know it comes
down to preference
uh oh you're gonna tweet out a
screenshot
yeah so we're gonna show off uh some a
share feature i guess
we're going to tweet straight from our
xbox right onto the gamespot account
uh make sure you like retweet subscribe
all that non-buddy you need catch up dog
uh but yeah so those are the the
enhancements that you get from
this game on the series x if you play on
the series s
you can choose um a lower resolution
for 60 frames per second i think it's
earlier i said it was 1080p i think it's
it's actually 900p
um so it's it's like it's can be
pretty blurry depending on your
perception
of that but it'll run 60 frames per
second if you play high resolution mode
it'll do 1440p 30 frames per second so
it's just scaling down
the um the resolution for this game i
don't know if there's any other visual
visual like settings or graphics uh
features
that also have to get cut down with it
but for me
the main thing i notice is the
difference in resolution uh going from
uh x to s
so oh man that's a lot uh i've been
running my mouth
uh a lot to talk about lots of questions
new console after all this only happens
yeah it only happens about
not every year at least yeah
lately it's gotten a little weird with
pro ps4 pro and xbox one x
but yeah um uh those guys are a little
too tough for me we're gonna stay away
i think i'm kind of getting to an area
where i'm not really supposed to be yet
yeah if you go to north uh northern
yokohama i think it gets a little tough
i don't i don't i
i think this game does a decent job of
level scaling
they do get they are harder the more
north you go but i don't think it's like
impossible hard i'm gonna check out some
of the sub story see if there's any
any good ones yeah got some real raunchy
sub stories in this game well that's
what i
want to get i want to get a screenshot
of a raunchy one so we can post to
gamespot twitter
okay all right hey they said they said
we could yeah we got to get
the kingdom we can do whatever we want
yeah didn't realize
uh we're gonna do it um
mrs lisa murphy 12. hopefully i said
that right
hopefully it's not mr slice lisa murphy
this is lisa murphy 12 says what are
your thoughts on nba action
i still need to jump on that i actually
just got it
just from what i've seen so far though
it looks like nba 2k
is one of the games that is actually
separating itself between
gen generations in terms of the virgins
that i come out with
so nba 2k on series x and ps5 is
almost a completely different game i
mean
you be the judge of like how much of a
difference between
basketball games or sports games uh that
is
um but it is a separate version that
has like players look
incredible i was looking at damien
lillard earlier that will look like
damien lillard
it's it's pretty it's pretty wild but i
wanna yeah i'm gonna check that out
uh soon today if not uh later this week
uh yeah
wayne harrison points out that black ops
cold war is 130 gigs on ps5 and xbox
oh boy uh that hard drive space is a
premium
because games are getting bigger
um i hope that
i mean if you're playing on the series s
and you play call of duty
i hope that um the devs or they
they offer like the slimmer download
install sizes because there are some
games that do that whatever
so if series s enhanced games such as
like sea of thieves is the biggest deal
i think
because that game is 44 something gigs
on the
series x but only 17 gigs
on the series s so they uh they cut out
a lot
of the unnecessary files for that that's
less than half the install size
um if you're on series s but there's
some game like gears
i think it's like 72 gigs down to 55
gigs
um so it saves a little bit of space
if you press if you press up on the
d-pad you can take a selfie i don't know
if you want to take a selfie and post
that to them
oh my beautiful boy kasuga ichiban
how do we just get a wholesome smile you
see
yeah you can you can turn around get the
get the squad and they will strike a
pose
as well
give them up give them in a minute i
think they'll
they'll put up they'll put a piece there
you go oh yeah there you go
give him the give him the doggy face
there you go
i actually i don't think it saves as a
full-on screenshot
uh i think it like saves your photos in
the game
uh and i don't know if you i don't think
you can do anything you can hide under
them
yeah all right well that's fine you just
see this
yeah there you go that's fine ui and
everything
um beautiful beautiful game
oh so cole austin asked i think
we answered this a little bit um earlier
but to give you um
straight up answer cole austin asks um
how much of the ssd is usable on the
series s
365 oh i see the chat 364 sorry
i see the chat has answered that uh yeah
but it is 364 gigabytes
uh once you get your console um
that's how much i had on mine uh 802
gigabytes free on the series x
let's see um
let's see
evan langer says he played chapter one
last night was super skeptical of egypt
since i love kiryu so much same uh but
i'm already oh
my god the thing i like about ichiban is
that he's he's his own
he's his own person can't share
whoa i'll try one more time
too many followers on that yeah maybe
it's like nine
um so yeah uh
yeah ichiban really really like
i feel like he's able to take ownership
of who he is
throughout the game to where like you
never think about like
oh does he live up to kiryu and majima
or anything like that ichiban is his own
person and
i love what he's about i think a lot
everyone's gonna love what he's about
um definitely one of my favorite
characters in games
um cole austin has another question
how big are triple a games looking
storage wise on new consoles it depends
um so for example like forza is like 80
something gigs forza horizon 4 that is
um
gears is like 70 gives 5 is like 72 gigs
or something like that
um obviously call of duty is going to be
upwards of 100 gigs i know warzone is
106 gigs i think
so yeah but uh like yakuza is
only like 37 something gigs
uh and like do eternal i think it's like
50 or something like that so it
fluctuates obviously but
yeah those huge triple a games though
our
master chief collection is like oh my
god well that's like five games in one
so of course that's going to take a lot
it's like a hundred seems like 118 gigs
as well
yeah but uh word on the street is that
the december update
i think is supposed to slim things down
uh who knows by how much though because
destiny is a huge game with a lot of
content so
it's not surprising that game is upwards
of 100 gigs
my bad my bad sorry
all right
let me see
uh cash cab tvs asks how's dirt five are
the graphics any uh
gameplay good i there's a review of dirt
five on gamespot.com you should check
out uh richard wakeling i believe did
that
um i can dirt five for a bit too if we
want to check it out at some point
oh yeah we could do that i do have it
installed maybe not for long though
yeah um but yeah dirt five
uh you know i think it's
you know what i'm saying uh no i i think
i think it's a decent racing game um
well it's a lot more arcadey than
maybe like dirt rally or dirt four was
um you're not gonna be like
you're not gonna have a co-driver saying
all right 40 degree turn
in 50 feet or some [ __ ] um wait is that
what the older ones were
uh some of them some of them not all of
them were like that
the early ones i bet yeah early ones
dirt 4
was i think dirt rally 2.0 if i'm not
mistaken
it was like that they did have like
rallycross and stuff like that more
traditional style racing but
some of it was sim simulation style
um graphics are good it's not going to
blow you away i don't think uh gameplay
is good so i can blow you away i don't
think
uh decent game it's got some
enhancements too if you wanna
that game can do 120 hertz yeah if you
want want to but
i think it's like image quality modes is
probably my favorite because it still
does
uh 60 fps pretty consistently uh that's
cool
fear no hate asks uh someone else asked
this earlier does it come on little game
pass
um does xbox come
bundle game pass not if you buy the
straight up console
there's no game pass code that comes
with it we talked about the
all access thing earlier where you can
get ultimate and console on layaway or
not layaway but on a payment plan
i know all about layaway growing up man
uh stuff in the streets yo uh but
uh so is this on game pass yakuza like a
dragon is not on
that so you have to buy a game strip and
i highly recommend it
let's see street fighter games coming to
xbox series x and s well they're
backwards compatible
i think uh yeah i mean
if they're on the one at uh xbox one
then
they will work i play a lot of street
fighter 4 on 360 back in the day
love that game uh let's see
have you done this is this the soap
the guy in the soapy yeah i did this one
this is good okay
i can get some screenshots of this one
oh my god this one
is so dumb
enjoy boy i hope you all can enjoy um
yeah no problem man
let's see uh any other questions what
are you talking about
call austin has another question are the
consoles compatible with any usb
ssd as long as you're connecting it
through a
usb 3.0 cable it'll work
so yeah i've been using a samsung t5
uh and i know that if you have an
enclosure if you have like
your own internal ssd and use an
enclosure and if you want to use that
through usb
3 it'll work you should be good there
oh my soapy guy man covered in bubbles
there's there's a lot of dialogue in
yakuza and it's all incredibly well
written written
and well localized
i imagine you did the you did this
the sub story for the to open up the
quiz minigame already right
yes i did okay because that has an intro
that's
pretty funny yeah it's pretty good yeah
there's also if you go to hamakita park
up in the north you can unlock the
dragon cart minigame
okay yeah i think that's just pretty
wild
yeah this way this one's this is this is
some yakuza for you for yoas
this is this is this is um how it is
this is why we love the series so much
it has everything you've ever wanted has
seriously some some dumbass situations
that are legit funny and then has like
some really really good drama
some heartfelt um moments
uh oh you're playing the you're playing
the english dub huh i am playing the
english dub
yeah i i can't get i'm not getting
gameplay audio so i wasn't
uh i'm not yeah i did it because i
wanted to hear george takai who
plays one of the uh the patriarchs
yeah he plays masumi aracawa uh major
character that's that's pretty i i need
to go i want to go back and play
i'm gonna play this game again because i
love it that much but i am gonna play
with the english dub
i messed around with the english dub a
little bit was like oh this is like this
is good
it's very well done um but being a
yakuza fan i have to play in japanese
i play anime games in uh with its
uh english dubs but for some like
obviously like a photo realistic game
set in japan i'm gonna play with the
japanese voices
also the japanese voiceover performance
absolutely stellar obviously
so much emotion and emphasis are put
into so many things
so jake is gonna have to escort his new
buddy who's covered in
soapy bubbles uh but you're also gonna
have to for some reason you're gonna
have to avoid
split sprinklers and people throwing
water in the streets
for some damn reason it doesn't matter
in the world of yakuza it don't matter
is that jose i know joe zija does does
some voices
uh i don't know who exactly um i know uh
kaiji tang
voice of gaius from trails of cold steel
uh
kaiji tang is the voice of kasich
ichiban which is huge
that's huge so shouts out to my guy
kaiju tang for for
stepping up into that role by the way
are you gonna play are you gonna play
dragon quest 11 now
michael i actually i actually started
dragon quest 11 because the
yeah because uh secret weeb jacob decker
um the dragon quest 11 demo went up
uh over the weekend i think and so it's
available now and i think it's about the
first 10 hours of the game
and that save that you have in the demo
will carry into the full version once it
comes out
and it's on game pass that is full man
game pass
is wild the best deal in games straight
up
so yeah i started dragon quest 11. um
echoes of an elusive age s definitive
edition
something like that dragon quest 11 s
echoes of an elusive age i think
yeah definitive edition don't forget
that um
but yeah i'm enjoying it i think it's uh
it's pretty simple uh in the early hours
like attack attack attack heal attack
attack heal but uh and the story is very
like
traditional style of fantasy rpg
um i guess but that's not to say
that it is not a great game because i'm
really excited i only dipped into it a
little bit on the ps4
when it came out didn't have time to
dedicate to it but this is the time i
think that's going to be like my
thanksgiving break
game uh that i'm just gonna sink into
it's very uh like it's segmented in a
way like
i feel there's an overarching story but
like it's very much like
you get tuna area you meet a whole new
cast of characters there's like subplots
you
solve from there and then you move on
with like someone new in your party or
just just new understanding and it kind
of pushes you through the world in that
way it's not until like the second half
where things kind of start to uh really
kind of build
um but it's still very good it's very
like wholesome and
and like i i don't know i i just found
it so hard to play that game without
like
leaving with a smile on your face
because it's just so clever
oh oh i put did power your dream though
just one you only got one yeah that's it
that's good though that's good though
check game spot twitter for me make sure
make sure it made it up safely
all right i got you i'm gonna check how
are you
no that i like that even better
that's hella funny oh my god
this full
oh that's what i get talking about
dragon quest while trying to type
doesn't work
uh it's all right that's
where am i taking this guy uh
you gotta take him yeah to that that
blue uh
bubble gotta avoid the at first i
thought you had to avoid the puddles
on the street which you don't you have
to just avoid the people for some reason
there's
this kid is just throwing water
everywhere first off there shouldn't be
a man covered in bubbles walking public
streets but you know what
hey he explained your situation it's
yeah it's tough out there for him
look at how beautiful isaki what is it
this is an isaki road but this is one of
the shopping areas of
um yokohama it's so bright and lively
but also ichiban just bumps into
everyone because he doesn't care
but he's a nice boy he's a nice boy i'll
promise you that
also cars follow traffic laws so if you
cross the street while they're driving
you can get hit and lose 100
hp there we go take him to get some
clothes
power your dream this
that [ __ ] is hella funny
oh man
let me see
okay uh let's see
if anyone else has a question
um mark bell's uh power project uh
re-asking
fizzy bros uh fizzy bro 26's question
can you stream to youtube from the xbox
series x
no i don't think so i haven't
i don't that's a damn
i don't think so i actually don't know a
different advantage
answers to that but i'm sure the answer
is out there my bad my bad
my bad uh that i don't know the answer
straight up but i don't think so
can we should we dig through the
dashboard to take a look or
yeah we can do that so we can give you a
little we're no longer
held to embargoes of not showing the
dashboard
uh consoles are out there so we can uh
we can take a tour of the ui
we have a video
because would there be a separate app
you'd have to install to stream because
i didn't do any streaming directly from
the xbox the only thing i had
at least from the xbox one the only
experience i had was streaming from
the uh ps4 which like you just hit the
share button
so with this i don't really know this is
just streaming off like stream labs like
i've got a capture card
that's it's plugged into and everything
yeah yeah um
i don't i don't think so because uh
obviously i dug through the share menu
and obviously on like on playstation
platform
that's part of like the share your
options when you open up your share
uh menu for that is like if you want to
hit stream but here it's like
record the last couple seconds or a
minute of gameplay
record gameplay and take screenshots
um so yes
uh let me see if y'all been saying some
other things
catch up real quick
exam
um fantasy thinker fan
asks which upcoming game xbox games are
you most excited for
what are you excited for jake it was a
question what x games
xbox games are you most yeah most
excited
i mean i'm this is kind of a cheap
answer but star field
is that yeah the the next game which now
i guess is
i don't know about that and that might
might be coming to multi-console or
might be coming other platforms but i'm
really excited for that game just
because there's going to be a new engine
um but apart from that i love the first
psychonauts game that's one of my
favorite games of all time
so i've been waiting a very long time
for a psychonaut sequel
so i am very happy that yeah that is
going to be happening i hope it comes
out soon
but i don't know double fines taking
their time and honestly
they should let him yeah that's that's
okay uh but yeah
yeah psychonauts too i saw it at e3 2019
uh saw it in action uh looks like a ton
of fun yeah i think i was with you
didn't we see that together yeah we did
we uh got the hand oh not the hands on
demo we got the the live demo in front
of us
uh yeah that looks yeah we we both uh
got that appointment
chopped it up with our boy tim schaefer
um but yeah second 2's uh i think it's
coming 2021 or
marlene you would hope uh so
that's that that's a good answer i think
that's an exciting day also yeah double
fine is now under the xbox game studios
umbrella
uh which happened fairly recently that's
pretty wild
for me for xbox damn
um i mean in the short term i think the
medium
is going to be an interesting one
because it's a series
x that game isn't coming to xbox one
that is a series x and s and pc
uh i guess exclusive to the the
next-gen platforms because
i i talked to bluebird team earlier
before
before they fully announced the game and
um
yeah they were talking about how the
game takes specific advantage of
the hard drive and sorry the ssd
and load times because they're doing
like a multi-dimensional
world swapping thing that is
part of the gameplay and it wasn't
possible on traditional hard drives and
older consoles
so i'm really really fascinated by how
the game is able to take advantage of
that
and to see if you know if that actually
like pans out or uh pays off
um because they they like blue team like
i think they do interesting things with
horror games
so the fact that they are trying to
leverage
uh the hardware in a in a new way is
exciting so in the show i think that's
coming that's coming in december this
year
i believe uh so that's in the short term
i'm just looking forward to playing all
of drag quest 11.
if i'm gonna keep it real with you um
but in the long term i think you know
easy one is halo infinite uh just
because
it's uh i don't know man halo is such a
weird thing in in like this
this past generation like the xbox one
generation like what is halo we got halo
5
and master chief collection but you know
obviously people have mixed feelings
about
halo 5. and
i think you know it was it was a is a
great game i think
but you know expectations are different
when it comes to halo so
to finally see and experience what
infinite
actually is is going to be yeah i
i just want to know i don't want to know
yeah i was playing halo 2 yesterday uh
on the master chief collection just
because
halo was sick halo 2 was 16 yesterday
which is crazy
but uh playing that i was like yeah i'm
really excited for infinite i hope
they can do something really cool and
interesting with that game because
i missed the days when halo was the
behemoth that it was i guess
not that it isn't anymore but i feel
like everyone i knew
was like getting halo 2. yeah
when that came out yeah i feel i
definitely feel you on that
um ben sussman
that's a question is it worth buying at
xbox series x
even though there's no launch exclusives
for the console will be exclusive
launching soon
um like i said like i just mentioned
earlier um the only one i really know of
is the medium like i said earlier
because that's taking advantage of
series x specific hardware
i think whether or not the series x is
worth it for you
you have to like ask yourself a couple
questions
like if you're on a i i say this in my
reviews like if you're on a xbox one x
and you're happy with that i think it's
i think it's fine to hold off on the
series x like you don't
this isn't something like you need to
like get right away like right now right
now
um because there's nothing that's
there's nothing gaining you from
experiencing anything that xbox is
putting out
you're still gonna have access to all
the same games um
they run best on series x and some of
the series x enhancements are legit
like really really good um if you have a
4k tv
uh you know that that's also a factor if
low if long load times are something
that
you really don't want to deal with
anymore
uh definitely consider getting into the
series x because the little times
that that that can change things it's
it's pretty i like that a lot
so yeah it just depends on what your
expectations are
you don't have to come out i wouldn't
say it's essential uh to go out and get
an xbox series x but
um yeah though if you if those
enhancements are attractive to you uh
you know i think it'll be worth it are
you trying to unlock dragon cart i am
yeah it's all the way up in the top
right corner of the of hamakita park
or actually straight ahead yeah there
you go
oh i see it
yeah it's it's a it's a short little
substory and then it unlocks
it locks for you uh so you can play a
cart racing minigame inside of yakuza
like a dragon
let me see if there are other questions
so that ben sussman hopefully that
answers your question
uh of course there's a lot of other
nuances to it but uh hopefully that's
oh
looking for questions
legit like rumblings yeah that it might
happen again
just rumors i don't think anyone like no
big websites have reported on it like
gamespot hasn't reported on it
um it was just a couple tweets that
someone tweeted something who's been
right before
so
allegedly allegedly allegedly yeah
allegedly temperature of
xbox series x on heavy load not that hot
actually
i think of mine yeah it's not bad at all
yeah
i was able to comfortably rest my hand
on it
yeah i i don't know if things have
changed from the preview unit to this
to the retail unit but yeah i've been
playing
all sorts of series x enhanced games so
games that are
in some capacity pushing the hardware
and
yeah heat is not an issue at all it is
a lot of folks have done like thermal
testing themselves
and showing that the series x is
actually running a little bit cooler
than the 1x
so yeah it's all good
um david k yeah points out uh from uh
gripritzing
that yeah the cooling system is very
robust and basically silent
facts uh it is silent like yeah i
hated it at all yeah unless you're like
in a a room that is what like
closed off from all sound maybe you'll
hear the span of the span
the fan spinning but yeah i don't
it is purely silent i have the series s
right here on my desk and i was playing
some games earlier today
and didn't hear it even though it's like
right up in my face
so that's cool like um i just feel like
xbox
or microsoft has really they built
something that is
just solid all around um at least
so my perception is that like ps5 like
ps5 i think will run
actually i should say i'll leave that up
to matt padgett the reviewer of the ps5
but xbox like the series x is such a
solid console
it does feel like the 1x in many ways
where it's an incremental jump because
you have
access to pretty much the same stuff but
uh obviously like very much improved
um but yeah it's just a solid piece of
hardware
um you're not gonna get like things like
the cool dual sense features because the
controller is
pretty much the same has some
improvements here and there
uh but yeah really good experience
overall
this if we can pull out a rocket
launcher
yeah first race is easy so you won't
need to pull out the rocket launcher
anymore but you can
because this mini game does get tough
no uh oh you have to bust shots at him
this is yakuza
this is uh or i think you can just use
the right stick
no yeah um
this is a game about adult men in crime
drama
in case you didn't know so
yeah this is uh game of the year
so after this race should we wrap up
with some gears
co-op or that sounds good yeah that
sounds good
um word on the street is that xbox live
has been in and out like down and out
for like a little bit here and there so
we'll see if we can join up
if so yeah let's let's go all right i
wonder if that's why i wasn't able to
post that
those pictures at first oh yeah but i
think we we it was good
that we weren't able to do that because
we found something better
yeah much much better uh that is going
to be i'll get i'll try and get rgg
studio to retweet that
uh they're never gonna give us control
of twitter again
hey well then let's go wild let's post
it for some others
some more [ __ ] all right uh
where's bubble guy keeping his wallet
good question between his cheeks
who knows
thank you for the question that was the
best question we got so far
you'll never know
these are the dragon cart out masters
let me see if there's any other
questions that i may have missed sorry
great job out there
noobs on master chief collection
you don't even know top of the
scoreboard all the time
all right uh i don't think that is
any other questions
relating to the consoles how stressful
is it for all the game spot team right
now
uh it's been a long stressful yeah um
obviously you know covering games is
what we love to do
but the sheer volume of things that we
need to and want to cover uh can
be a little overwhelming and especially
during like a
next-gen console launch um expectations
are high
there's a lot of a lot of variables lots
and lots of variables that you can't
really
um anticipate so like things working
working from home transferring files
being able to hit
embargo deadlines all other stuff just a
lot
lots of juggle for everyone on board
like i did three reviews in one week
jake also stayed up late to cut the
video versions with me
like um and then uh
obviously on ps5 stuff there's like a
lot of people working working late to
make sure
we hit those make sure those videos are
on points because you watch that ps5
review
that video review is on point you watch
the xbox series x review on video
that's on point you watch the yakuza
like a dragon video review i rewatched
it this morning
i just got a desktop notification for
getting an achievement in this game you
didn't see it on stream because i turned
off notifications because i don't want
people to
blow up my dms as they're watching this
uh
but yeah it just linked to my pc which
was interesting
oh yeah yeah sometimes i come back to my
pc and i have a bunch of achievement
notifications
from let's play on xbox um
but yeah i think xbox live is
up do you have me are we even friends on
xbox live i don't think so
damn i'll have you i'll have you add me
though
okay mine's just jacob deck same as
everything else where's your stairs i
have my monitor posted i have my monitor
posted up at a
certain angle here on my setup so my bad
if
i look weird in the pip um
find someone
jacob decky oops
um that also means i can't pay attention
to the chat
all that much no i had
trouble already add fwind can you be my
friend
did you send it i sent it
just right now should get it
i'm gonna be friends with jakey
um cole austin really coming through
with the questions wow
um asks uh what the way stuff is
uh is now how long do you think until
new consoles will be jailbroken
oh can't can't
can't talk to you about that one um
will goncher has a question if the
improvements between
xbox one x and the series x are
incremental how big of an upgrade is the
series x from the
base mod it's a huge like from c from
base model xbox one to the series x it's
huge yeah
huge uh because i was talking earlier
box one struggled to do 1080 in some
cases it like
barely did 900p yeah
um so the the difference is huge
obviously like it's launch it's launch
window so
games are running and looking great but
they're not taking
they're not able to take full advantage
of the series x of course
couple years down the line maybe next
year or two years from now you're really
going to see games take full advantage
of what the series x
can do um but yeah
running original x like the og bass xbox
is it's like night and day it really is
that that really feels like a
generational jump
because i like we had a 1x in the middle
of a console generation so it kind of
takes the edge off of a full console
generation jump right
um so that's maybe why the series x
doesn't feel
like it's making huge strides based on
the
1x it is in some ways but um
we've seen the 1x do some incredible
things i don't see your friend request
michael um so what is yours let me just
add you oh wait there it is
friends so i can join your party no
we're good
okay did you send me an invite
awesome friends and now what
what do you want to do do you want to do
campaign you want to do horde probably
not versus that might be a little too
stressful on stream
yeah um maybe we could do horde horde
all right
yeah i actually haven't played horde
mode in gears 5. i played it in
previous gears so it's really good good
luck
yeah horde mode is a lot of fun oh i've
had a lot of fun with horde mode in the
past
let me jump into your game look at these
boot times even on a series s so i'm
playing on series s
um but yeah this thing is well gear
gear swipe does take a little while to
boot up regardless
uh but way faster than the 1x i'll tell
you that much
um
let's see
uh someone mention oh wow i got the
my pc notification too i'm still i'm
still i'm trying to
these um splash these developer splash
screens
are a lot
the ssd ssd is fast but it isn't gonna
cancel out those uh those splash screens
those are built into the game
um someone mentioned assassin's creed
valhalla on xbox series x if you want to
check that out
jacob decker who's above me and lucy
james good friend uh streamed that
yesterday
let's go and check that out played off
the series x
um like i said
if you missed it assassin's creed
60 fps on a console
pretty nice i'll say that
um xbox live is acting a little funky
for me
it's been trying to join for a minute
now
here we go i'm in oh you're in oh there
you are
i will be our good friend kate diaz
phil with bots yeah we'll fill with bots
because i feel like
it's tough to do this without having at
least
four people i don't know what hard
frenzy is
survive 12 waves of enemies we'll do
horde frenzy because that's a little
shorter than 50 waves
i bet it'll be harder but that's fine
we'll be all right i think no promises
um i'm gonna be master chief
chad's gonna give me that's not master
chief oh i guess
it's it's a meal from uh reach
oh okay yeah ah
boy uh errol m in the chat says i heard
jake watches a lot of anime true
that's facts yup errol m shouts out to
arrow
thanks for joining us man hey earl
howdy howdy howdy um
can you play any cods on the new xbox
yeah they're all they all work
all cods all cods all gods
i guess everyone that would have come to
xbox 360
or one would all work yup
i think the og og cod that i played on
pc all those years ago
actually i don't have actually i think
they did end up bringing that to 360
like arcade huh yeah so i don't have
sound
uh off the game because i have my
headphones on so i can hear the
wonderful sultry tones of one jacob
decker so
uh my bad if i can't hear anything
secure the fabricator
oh yes there's the fabricator again
oh it's a fabrication so we like move
this to
a place we want to defend more or less
i'll get on the other side
okay all right what do we want to move
this there we go
uh moving moving maybe maybe above us i
think there's like a nice little
oh i don't know probably one in the back
corners of the map
yeah maybe right here all right let's
keep going
back for the bed okay right over here
yeah okay michelle i need you to guide
me because i am not a horde expert
okay so nothing's going to come from
that gate
i know right sick what do i got i got an
asher and i got
a retro lancer all right so so then you
go to the fabricator to build like
defenses and stuff
so you can get barriers decoys centuries
you probably can't get anything yet um
oh i see yeah but as you kill enemies
um and whatnot you should get some
ah snap
got we're on that on that wave we're on
that chase green wave
oops it's probably not great position
but
oh it's good it's good
i love i really like how gears did like
um what's it called the active reload
i think that's cool i do wish that
active reload was on the center of the
screen
so i can actually see it while i'm
trying to aim as well
maybe that's part of the challenge oh
snap let's do a trip in the business huh
his hands at that point
if you were playing versus multiplayer
you could do 120 hertz if you have 120
hertz display
um with the xbox series x which is
pretty cool like i've been able to do
that on my
because i have a tv that's able to do
120 hertz
and at least to me it's noticeable
because i've been playing where am i
going i've been playing games
at my pc i have a 144hz
monitor for my pc uh so that's been like
pretty standard for me like i'll be
playing
uh called any shooter really
a lot of counter-strike at 144 hertz
uh final fantasy 14 at 144 hertz
you know the vibes and going back to 60
is wild noticeable
but i also think like it also
the differences are a lot more
noticeable when you're playing on a
keyboard and mouse where there's a lot
more um
precision based stuff and precise aiming
but it is a nice feature that you can
have in a game such as gears 5
when you are playing competitive
multiplayer
also you can hook up a keyboard and
mouse to the xbox right
i haven't tried it's something i've
wanted to do i mean i imagine you can
but like when i was looking at uh
bright memory there were mouse and
keyboard options in the menu which
i don't know if that was just a mistake
or not but
yeah um but also you this cross play
with pc players
and if you are playing on a keyboard and
mouse
which i usually prefer to do that is
that's not right a really good barrier
okay our currency is uh shared across
the team right
no i don't think so okay oh wait no
maybe it is
i have 2177 though
oh i have way more yeah i just bought
something so that's probably why
it's not across it's been so long since
i've done
board mode i played a lot of it though
uh with um
dan reichert and mike mccarty when it
came out
which was shouts out to the boys it was
fun
we got some enemies coming this way oh
it's not rifle came from the other side
let's go
man i'm yeah
i forgot what these things do i think i
can like build something here and get
more resources
but i don't know how to oh
i let this full slip my bad
it's all good
you know cool thing too is like i mean i
think
this is a cross this is pretty standard
i guess across like the generation of
jump but like
all backwards compatible games are
cross-platform multiplayer anyway
yeah because the xbox
platform just treats the series x and s
as basically just another xbox
it's all the same ecosystem i've said
this in my very very first preview
um a couple months ago when we first got
the series x but
yeah it's like i'm playing with uh folks
on pc playing with folks on xbox one
uh it's all it's all the same in terms
of
the xbox live recognizing what platform
you're playing on
which is standard now but before it was
it's not like that
you know back in my day
you can have that
all right i'm buying a turret
all right cool
i'm like putting no forethought into
what i'm placing at the moment
i mean having it can't hurt oh snap i'm
moving real slow but i need to uh
set down this turret though oh you
already sat down turned off that one
down
yeah and set another one down i just put
it a little further up maybe
yeah i'll do that make sure we cover our
flanks
as best we can
the sound design in these games are
always so good
i know it's like so juicy it's so
dramatic
like i i hate it i almost hate it
but i'm almost like like you're shooting
someone and it sounds
more like you um
punched into a slab of ground beef
that's what that sounds like which isn't
bad but i'm just like
that's nasty man
the entire uh gears franchise is on xbox
game pass
if you are so interested um the ultimate
edition of the original gears two
three judgment on how you all feel about
your judgment
that's also available i did not neither
did i
i played judgment the rgg studios game
but i now play gears of war judgment i
i've played all of them except judgment
uh i've never been like a huge gears fan
so i don't really feel the need to play
judgment but i've heard some people say
it's actually pretty good
and some people say they're not so i
don't know such as like
he has opinions he certainly does
most of which are good he doesn't have
some happiness
not everyone's got all good opinions
though you know
yeah that's that's true as well
shouts out to our guy
um
yeah gears of war 4 is also available
too um
i feel like gears of war 4 was
it was all right i had to force myself
through that before five came out
because i was excited for this one
uh and i was like all right i'm just
gonna play this game and i
it was tough to get through yeah it's
it's your
it's pretty standard gear stuff which is
good but it's not like groundbreaking or
anything but
i really like the how they um retooled
the story
uh for five not that i was never really
like huge into like gear story i'm like
oh it's
thick dudes with thick necks and huge
arms fighting
alien swarms i'm like cool that's good
enough for me to play this
really thick cover shooter um but i
really like kate
i really like how they uh make the focus
on her and
uh i think that was probably the biggest
misstep before was that
even though like kate was supposed to be
one of the main characters he played
jd power and associates yeah exactly
yeah jd is like whatever to me
he's fine as like a support character
but i don't think he was very
interesting as a lead
um did you play through gears 5 should
you get to the end of it
i did because there's some interesting
implications at the end of this game
yes yeah y'all should play it
it's it's really good um oh sh damn this
won't come at me with a hammer though
this dude's mad what did i do
oh he's blocking my shots there you go
get him
cool oh i can pick it up i'll get the
breaker mace ooh
what's good
oh this thing is heavy
i wish i could get the sound of me
smashing a fool with this
this hammer oh
they're dodging okay this is not us this
is not necessarily smart but
that was fun all lasted done
okay oh
here we go oh another another warden i'm
trying oh what's good what's good oh
that doesn't have to have damage
that's useful damn for
so i think we messed up by not having a
uh
i don't know what they're called tech
guy or whatever to repair the turrets
i think there's like a class you pick
up air stuff damn i bet there's a bunch
of fools and uh fools in chat talking
[ __ ] about our
horde shields that's fine it's fine you
know it's been a while
since uh it's been a while i was gonna
do that
play gears it's been a while
didn't creed get back together
i mean if it's going to happen it'll
probably happen in 2020 right yeah hey
listen with wa arms wide open
social distance you can't do arms wide
open oh yeah
damn with the arms wide open
damn that that style of singing was very
uh
it's very prominent yeah that's like
that was like didn't pearl jam kind of
any better
a pioneer i would say but but yeah and
then a bunch of like
fans in the 90s did that like or or
early 2000s yeah like nickelback
kind of did that too yeah hey eddie
better didn't even know what he started
man you know
he's like damn i shouldn't have done
that program is one of your one of your
goat bands right
yep uh lead blood zep deck
oh yeah i know you're you're into uh
oh we saw arctic monkeys together also
facts
there was a point of my life before i
had heard do i want to know and there
was a point after
it should change man i know like oh
alex because like i've been um uh arctic
monkeys fan for quite a while
um and the shift between uh am
from oh it was gradual but like the the
shift like the the suave and sexy style
of
arctic monkeys i was like oh yeah we're
doing we're doing this now all right
alex turned like
looking a little different because he
was always like that the scruffy
um boyish dude
at least that was my perception through
the first couple albums
and also i'm like okay this will got a
slick back and everything he's trying to
be like a little biker dude
i'm like all right i think about arctic
monkeys dudes like each album they
change their sound so drastically yeah
i think that's really interesting
because like it always to me i mean i
don't know how i feel about like
was it the latest one the hotel
something i like some of the songs on it
i like the lyrics i think more than the
songs themselves on that album
okay yeah i feel you on that but it i
definitely didn't listen to it as much
as their other stuff i think i listened
to it like couple times and then uh
i listen to some songs every now and
then yeah
while we're in a uh horde break for at
least a second let me
see if i can pull any sorry uh as i've
been playing gears i haven't been able
to see the chat
um i think before we sign off though
i'll try and scroll back through
and answer any uh
questions jump around on some other
games oh yeah or whatnot
i don't know if we want to go for all 12
rounds
but we can do a couple more yeah let's
do a couple more
um and then yeah so if you've been
asking questions in the chat sorry
because i've been playing you know
um playing a little gears horde with my
guy jacob decker um
but if you had a question while we're
playing gears i'll try and get to him
afterwards or if you just wanna
after we get off this if you want to
restate it in the chat uh so i can
see it easier that would be dope as well
oh let me bust out the mace get out you
can always
get one of us too yeah we're
available on twitter
we got a lot of things going on here at
gamespot but
you know i hate these things these are
like destiny
oh i'm getting frozen oh [ __ ] there's a
big ass dude right here oh
my god oh no i got frozen and shattered
can i revive you uh i think next wave i
come back
okay or maybe you can bind me back to
you
have to go i have to go back to the
foundation thingy
as they say in uh gears universe
and then i think you take them back or i
got too many
you either do that or you um uh or just
i think i come back at the next wave
jacob deck [ __ ] tags carry teammates
cocktails back to the fabricator to
resurrect them costs will increase each
time
um enemies or a friend is revived
all right i'm back oh [ __ ] you're back
okay cool
sick sick i'm just saying i've been i've
been mvp most of these rounds so
these bots got nothing on me
you're not even seeing your feet i know
you guys some real gamer gamer skills
out here
i can't even see it it's all right
i'm really i'm really digging the feel
of the the new xbox controller
um it's not all that different but the
the textured grips on them
yeah i really like the old controller
for
doing some tests on the xbox one uh and
immediately like i was like oh yeah i
definitely prefer
the new controller with the the textured
grips and even i feel like the smaller
like the slightly smaller size just like
fits a little better and it's one of
those things that i didn't notice when i
first picked it up but when i was like
swapping between the controllers i was
like oh yeah i can
feel that yeah definitely and the
defense is
much better as well yeah i like the i
like the d-pad
it's pretty loud though it's loud wow
so i feel like when when bless is asleep
and i'm like gaming in some real late
gamer hours
like two o'clock in the morning i'm like
i'll try to limit the use of the d-pad
we got some we got thin walls out um
here
sure he doesn't mind because he's a real
gamer too he understands he gets it
yeah but also apparently he sleeps like
a baby
baby bless baby bless doo doo doo doo
probably hear me right now you know as
wild as waking up every morning to
him introducing games daily i'm just
like
oh [ __ ] like if i'm not awake by the
time he's doing games daily i'm like
i'm i [ __ ] up like i should be awake
at that time
oh snap oh i'm not dead i'm dead
thank you thank you oh jake save
this
me
looks like the eyes of the organ eyes
and destiny or something
try and get that oh you can shoot its
little gatling gun if you're precise
enough
i'm not i'll wait to leave these guys
are not like advancing
they're just they're completely relaxed
being back there
i know they're playing cover shooter too
oh
i'm getting frozen i'm getting frozen
invisible
that mace the breaker mace is nice
all right now we got this this destiny
turret oh it's pulling up it's pulling
up let me get an angle
just get it i'm just trying to get under
it yeah
it's not working that well oh
this thing's too fast our turrets can't
do anything either
yeah oh we got another freezer freezer
boy
let me get him with the mace what if i
can get the
mask this turns fast father
ah [ __ ] no i died or um
thank you for picking me up
mvp wave 7 complete
uh you wanna do one more and then uh
switch over yeah we'll do one more you
can answer some more questions and we'll
finish up i can just jump between
the games i have which i guess is like
dirt is the yeah
i think that'll that'll work just fine
see what else is there maybe not there
maybe what maybe what chat wants to do
obviously yeah based on what i have
obviously i can't download something
right now
i mean i could but you wouldn't be able
to see it in a couple hours
i need some i need some some ammo
it's that cryo cannon i don't know uh no
i don't want to switch it i like
i like having the mace is really clutch
for um sticky situations so i'm gonna
hold on to that
oh we got a carrier
oh my god this horde is this wave is
something else
oh no i almost destroyed oh i think it
went down all right
thanks god
okay i'm going to try and hit see if
what i can do with the mace
the breaker mace on this carrier let me
try
and get all the route maybe so not front
this is a big-ass crab oh there's other
enemies that are shooting at me
damn oh
this might be our last one even if we
don't want it to be yeah
cause we are not real gamers
at that camel and hit him with his face
oh [ __ ] oh he's gonna eat me oh
my god did you see that yeah
this will pick me up with one hand and
toss me away
damn i have like not invested in any uh
which is bad yeah we got we have too
confident
you know and our shooting skills our
spicy shooting skills
well since i am dead not for them
he just needed more ammo right so i'm
just died yeah
thank you and you all watched smallville
back in the day
am i doing it oh yeah you're back yeah
i'm alive i'm live
superman show i used to think back that
show made me think that
lex lex luger lex luthor
lex luger is a hip-hop producer
lex luthor uh ice thing oh man lex
luthor that that's the boy
he's got he's got uh spider-man
spider-man what the hell superman's back
clark kent that's my guy
that's luther that's my guy oh he's done
yay sick
still some sentences up in the sky
though
sentinels in the sky my new my new post
rock band
listen to explosions this guy
i went to a post rock costume
people are ignorant they were like
where's the lyrics where's the lyrics
like yo
you went to you went to a post-rock show
there's another carrier aw man oh well i
got it i got a couple rockets i can fire
up
all right let's let's see this let's do
this buddhists
shotgun shells
that active reload get these critical
hits
thousands of damage critical hits on
that unfortunately oh i'm dead again
i'm getting some oh my god i got two
kills
yeah you got too close
and that fool will smash you to pieces
my bad oh oh no i might die
no ah snap hopefully one of these ais
look at that booty meat though all right
should we uh
yeah a sad way to go
but oh you got revived i'm watching your
feed right now
oh really yeah you got revived oh i did
all right he's right up trying to finish
this wave
carrier though
what is up with today i'm just like on
like
odd rock bands which i haven't listened
to in years
a little bit can't wake up
man you know how many damn amvs were
made to that that song
bullet too many problems too many
evidences lincoln part man oh and
now i got smash ah [ __ ] uh hopefully i
don't get too close
let me get this tags oh
my god all right all right
now that's empty we failed failed
i got a little too spicy there i tried
to save my friend and i
died oh well that was fun
thanks jack uh okay do you want to
answer a couple more questions before we
close out and then
chat what do you want to see michael you
have to let me know because i can't see
it but
okay here are our options i can't really
play anything outside of this right now
yeah all right first person in chat to
say something that we haven't played
that is available
on this screen right now in jacob
decker's library of video games
on the xbox series x let me know first
pursue says something that is what we'll
play
sorry um
i am going to if no one says anything in
10 seconds i'm going to say
brrrr how does bright memory look
let's do that okay is that what people
want
uh or uh so cole austin who's been a
great person in the chat
says uh go through the menus real quick
i want to see
some things and then
i've got most recent game settings
game pass here ea play is now here too
which is nice
a lot of people saying valhalla um
gamer's corner universe is no violent
due to spoilers please but
you're not how do you feel
i don't have to do story stuff we did
stream valhalla for about an hour and a
half yesterday
um i don't know if that feat is still up
on youtube
though uh so we we could do valhalla
um if we want is that it yeah
yeah uh multiple people said about hala
okay uh some people said some other
things sorry
we had to choose one um let's see if
quick resume picks up because i did play
this some more recently
and i didn't close it cut quicker zoom
all right
hey oh wow look at that ooh
xbox series x go net quick resume you
know what i'm saying
uh that's a really cool feature because
that works even though you unplug your
xbox or if you turn it off
um because i was moving my xbox between
rooms
for different setups and then i would
move it and then i would jump back into
the games
straight up like once i rebooted it from
replugging it in that's that's pretty
wild but that's how um
uh that is how the xbox series x works
which is a really neat feature
okay so while jake does a little bit of
uh ac valhalla not too much
because we are trying to close this
thing out soon i'm going to go back
through the chat uh pick up some
questions
and also there are some remaining
questions
from our document that i didn't get to
i'll make sure i get to those at least
all right thomas leader asks as game
reviewers has your
as your enthusiasm bring strong or
diminished gaming in general
uh that's a not an xbox question but it
is a question nonetheless i think that
it has strengthened my enthusiasm
because i've been
um i've been exposed to a lot more
different
styles of games and i think a lot of
people i've interacted with
have shared their passion in ways that i
didn't see before
so it rubs off on me and i do the same
in turn so
um still loving games
more so than i did before as well is
this xbox series x
60 frames gameplay second um i'm not
sure if it's native 4k or if it's like
800p or does like dynamic resolution
i need to look into it more uh maybe
digital foundry did something
i'll try and see but the fact that it
runs 60fps on a console
i like that sky armada and chad thanks
for showing up
um someone from uh
from our little small community that
watched me
beat touhou luna nights which is on xbox
game pass and probably one of my
favorite series x titles
can you go live someone asked this
earlier but uh dolia asks also can you
go live
uh from the xbox straight to youtube i
don't think so bran
says hey michael and jake happy tuesday
happy tuesday to you as well
uh let's see
austin oh yeah you asked if you can go
through ui and menus yeah we did that a
little bit if you want to see more
though we do have a video that just
takes
takes you through all the a lot of the
different menus and stuff but not too
different from the xbox one
let's see
uh any more pre-orders opening this week
i have no idea
uh that is out of my control and beyond
my knowledge but
i think a lot of people including
gamespot are
trying to post articles like when things
go up on on sale because i know
as we talked about earlier it's a little
hard to get hands on
console during launch you know the state
of the world
and just the demand for new consoles is
have
changed things for launch so might be a
little tough even people getting
uh who pre-ordered are getting them a
little late which is unfortunate but
uh is the way of the world um
yeah so
wilden was digging my baby blessed tune
thank you
yesterday some people thought we were
game stop and they were asking us for
more pre-orders
they're like where's my damn pre-order
yeah pretty much
why are you streaming uh
sorry i think you got us confused here
oh uh no no the funny [ __ ] was
all alright a little story is i
interviewed method man for
a um for a couple because he did uh he
did a voice pack for call of duty
advanced warfare or something i think it
was advanced warfare
no infinite war infinite warfare he did
a voice pack for that so i interviewed
him about it
and then at the end of it he was like
you guys are game stop right i was oh no
no no no no this is game spot
case might say oh okay okay because i
was about to i was able to ask you about
about some [ __ ] i ordered
i was like i had a great interview with
method man but i'm not trying to get
roasted by method man over the phone
uh probably would have been a great
story to tell but i don't want that heat
the only question matters where can i
buy one like i said
it's tough not game
um or gamespot because we will publish
articles about
where you can get them it's true yeah
but we cannot give them to you
i see great sing was uh giving out some
information as well
thank you for that series x does come
with an hdmi 2.1 cable
so yeah robert rolfe asks uh the cable
that does come with the series x
and s are hdmi 2.1 cables
so if you look at the if you look at the
cable it'll say ultra high speed
that's how you know it's 2.1 so don't
just unplug your
xbox and use the same same hdmi cable
you can't use the same power cable
though
yeah i kind of like to have the new
cables all plugged in
just to make sure that i'm using all the
stuff that is packaged the thing
um pernell hunter asks a good question
what is loading like from an external
hard drive
i did um i did a video earlier about the
different
uh external hard drive options and how
they perform
so it depends if you use an external ssd
through usb 3 the load times are pretty
good
uh they're pretty close to the internal
ssd because
i don't think most games take full
advantage
of the internal ssd yet but it's still
very fast
external ssd works really well but you
can only play
backwards compatible games that have not
received uh
x enhancements if they have received x
enhancements or our series x game they
need to be on the internal drive
or through the seagate card if you get
one but yeah a load of times not bad if
you use an external hard drive
so not an ssd but a traditional hard
drive um
they're still pretty decent they're
better than the internal xbox
one hard drive if you use a usb
3.0 external s hard drive on
the series consoles it'll be a little
bit faster than that for example
just one example so i don't go on final
fantasy 15
loaded in a minute something seconds i
think like i'm in 11 seconds
on the one x internal uh series x
external hard drive loaded in like
40 16 seconds eight seconds yeah
um it's a little bit better but still
you know
also limited to like i said limited to
back compact games so it's a good
question
options to stream to facebook gaming i
don't think so can't help you buddy
let me see if anything else
has been said oh thomas lear uh asked
that question again cool cool
yeah i heard jake only watches some
anime full metal alchemist if you get
the reference okay
full metal alchemist i have seen some of
full metal
i saw the episode that damore likes to
tweet about all the time oh yeah
you got four episodes in and you're
already like oh that [ __ ] is
wild fma goes places that
that they change their tone quite
drastically from episode
or even within episodes um so okay
i think that's in the chat if i didn't
get to it please restate it real quick
in the chat uh so i can get to it before
i close out but i'm going to jump to
some pre
um pre-sourced questions make sure i get
to them
uh well microsoft was uh not much
not so much interested in the console
right now but do you think they will
show by any chance something related to
halo infinite i hope they do uh
my sharma on youtube
that's hard to say um i feel like
halo isn't halo infinite is a spot where
it's like
you will see it when we see it whenever
they're ready
uh it's been through it seems like it's
been through a lot
uh who knows uh what state of the game
is right now uh but you know
i expect this you know probably next
year yeah i don't think i wouldn't
anticipate this year
there's already enough going on this
year that i don't think it's necessary
to
come out and give an update on a life
and if they do cool
if not don't be surprised but i
definitely think that's something we're
gonna we're gonna definitely focus on
for next year because that is
now a 2021 release
um
here's another question from justplay on
twitter when will series x be
oh we've answered this in various ways
uh one will be able to be available for
retail local independent stores and mom
and pop shops
pop shops in particular they could be
there right now
they could not be there until later in
the year who knows
it's just uh if you really want a series
x or s
just keep tabs on your on your retailers
of choice
because like i said earlier stock comes
in and out
uh kind of sporadically i suppose
um so yeah i think that's all the
community questions that we sourced
beforehand
i was able to get to all those uh
i hope you answered your questions well
enough
wait wait does the hollows have the same
naval combat as odyssey
that is not a series x question but no
does not it's
well i mean i don't know i've only been
through the riverways and it's
there's like no you can't like fire
archers fire archers you can't like have
your arches shoot arrows off the side
and stuff it just seems the boat's more
for raiding and getting from point a to
point b
cool yeah there's like there's like auto
pathing too which i think is very
helpful
so we answered this a little bit earlier
but just to answer it real quick again
god and awesome
how's the heat i have one x the sucker
gets hot too hot the game
glitches and crashes oh yeah you got
that checked out but the new system
series xns
um perfectly fine on the thermals
doesn't get too hot gets a little warm
but all
you know technology um if it pushes out
a lot of heat
that means the cooling system is working
really well uh but yeah system stays
relatively uh
cool and very very quiet as you said
earlier i'll touch the top yeah we've
been streaming for
two and a half hours now right and i
it's not that hot like i can touch it
hold my hand there comfortably
yeah how's it feel world feel compared
to origins honestly that's that's an
assassin's creed question
um it feels more englandy
facts you can check out our review
though uh jordan remain did a
very very um detailed review on
gamespot.com
uh you can check that out video version
as well
uh did you cut that you cut that video i
did right oh my god i can't believe you
did it
i did uh home screen looked the same as
xbox one
similar very similar dynamic backgrounds
but
um yeah as you can see here very similar
to what you see on the xbox one
as we showed earlier are astonished by
the improvements in the graphics series
x
um did you or jake review and video
cards i
i reviewed all the nvidia cards um
i like the improvements going from uh
different from the new
from old consoles to new consoles uh
video cards are a whole other level
though
so i have reviewed those so you can
check those out as well
um are the consoles fine just using them
on a monitor
that's what i'm doing i mean yeah
they're um if you have 4k monitor
you're definitely going to be able to
push that 4k uh get all the same
enhancements
um will we start capturing and streaming
in 4k with hdr
that is an airtight question i
i doubt hdr 4k is a little bit tough
right now just because
uh it depends on people's internet
connection since we're all working from
home
so i wouldn't hold your breath i will
say you can expect more 4k videos on
our youtube channel though because the
series x reviews we've done so far
which are yakuza and
well spider-man as well i think was also
4k so there are 4k reviews there now for
some of these next-gen games if you want
to
take a look at that yep hdr is a little
trickier because there's
um capture equipment specifically to
capture hdr but also
you don't also need a monitor to do that
people who watch it
um also i know some phones have hdr
uh but yeah it's it's sort of a limited
use case
i imagine years down the line it'll
become standard but not anytime soon i
don't think
um 4k takes a lot of bandwidth too and
like jake said working from home um
gotta pick and choose your battles when
it comes to that stuff
so yeah
does rarity tracing add a dramatic
difference in graphics uh it can
depending on how it's implemented
because ray tracing is a kind of a
spectrum
of different features so far on consoles
we've only seen it on watchdogs legion
and it does make a big difference
sometimes not for the best like i said
earlier
if you like uh your england to look like
oil slicks
and it gets really rainy then ray
tracing can be a little overbearing
but it is a cool feature that i um that
we expect to see implemented because it
can make a big
uh visual difference though it'll
probably be at the expense of perform
performance um on a new any word on a
new skyrim
take it over todd howard i know that
that man's rubbing his hands he's like
hoo-hoo new consoles
skyrim special special edition you know
what i'm saying
um so i know he's got that cooking psych
don't don't
take that from me was it all right on a
like some seller was like skyrim next
gen or something like that
i i would just make that up i'll be i'll
pull a walmart canada and like just make
it up yeah there's a
stir drama um
does ray tracing work on minecraft i
don't know i don't think so
i know it was uh it's on pc it was one
of the showcases for nvidia rtx
i don't i don't think i've heard
anything about that coming to xbox
who knows um i might not have the most
updated information on that last
question though i will
i will answer before it closes out
because we are hitting two and a half
hours
in one minute cole austin hey mvp call
austin shouts out to you
thank you so much for chilling in the
chat asking a bunch of good questions
i really appreciate that so what feature
on this console is most intriguing
to each of you jake what is it
most intriguing i mean i don't know i
think it's just a lot of the quality of
life stuff for me that
makes it really cool and like the fact
that i'm able to do 4k60 on a lot of
these games is really nice the quicker
zoom is really cool
uh i don't really need to think about a
lot of um
that kind of stuff which is nice uh but
like
it's hard to point to one specific thing
because i think it's just the experience
as a whole
that has been greatly improved it's not
like the playstation for example where
you'd be like
the dynamic or the what are they called
the haptic triggers or like the thing
that i really like about this new
console i just kind of like the whole
package
yeah i echo jake's sentiments uh the
same i think that
i pretty much said that in my review as
well that
it's just like xbox kind of like takes
care of
all these little different corners of
the
gaming experience takes care of that
shorts them up but it's low times quick
zoom
uh boosting games fps if it allows it
doing series x enhancements doing like
cross-platform stuff
uh it's just i feel like it's a solid
solid package
nothing's gonna blow you away right now
but i think if i were to just say
the most intriguing thing for me is
probably load times
that's uh boring answer but like
if when i actually sit down and play
games that is the thing that probably
affects
what i'm able to do the most so
uh all right i think
that is it for me yeah yep that's it so
two and a half hours pretty good stream
saw a lot of cool games interesting
games on this brand new console
hopefully those of you trying to get
yours
you'll get it and hopefully those of you
who ordered it it'll come today or very
soon and it's not going to get
delayed till december or whatever
best of luck to you but uh yeah this has
been fun i've been able to chop it up
with
with jake which i haven't been able to
do in the in this this lockdown so uh
the fact that just crashed oh damn it i
hate to see it
okay we got one card xbox is telling us
to stop too
way to close out the xbox series crash
oh but it's been it's been a solid solid
experience so
um i guess i'll outro this by saying
thank you all for watching
thank you all for uh chilling with us uh
hitting us up with questions
hope you enjoyed your time here and uh
yeah if you want to jump into the
consoles best of luck to you to get one
or if you already have one
hope you enjoy it uh jake thank you so
much for spending time with me because i
miss you dog
i miss you too it was fun we had a good
time yeah and uh you know
we're doing a whole bunch of stuff on
gamespot.com so reviews of the latest
games reviews of all these consoles
uh matt page and i took care of the
hardware stuff folks like jordan
and callie's been killing it uh jake's
been cutting a lot of videos jean-luc's
become cute tam has been calling shots
huge team effort i'm really really proud
uh to be part of gamespot for all the
stuff that we're doing next gen
and we have a lot more on the way which
you all should check out on the site on
our youtube page
all that good stuff also shouts out to
jean-luc for um
putting together some extra life stuff
information on that is coming soon
we'll get to that but uh keep your eyes
peeled for that and keep your eyes
peeled for all of our cover of these
next-gen i guess we can't even say
next-gen no more
current gen the current den consoles
is here this week we will also do a
similar launch stream for the
playstation 5. so come back for that i
forgot to announce
this stream yesterday during the
assassin's creed stream uh but i am
remembering this time so come back on
ps5 launch day and you can check out
all sorts of stuff um i think they're
going to be playing spider-man for sure
and maybe they'll dabble in some other
games as well
hey get tam on that thing and play
bloodborne those vibes yeah or demon
souls get tam on play dean's
that's gonna yeah that ps5 launch stream
that's coming this week
is gonna be it's gonna be pretty hype so
stick around for that and yeah
thank you and peace y'all